[Music]
[Applause]
today we're participating an executive
challenge will participate in a series
of role plays and hopefully bring home
the trophy I'm really excited to kind of
take our learnings and put it in action
the entire quarter has been about what
kind of a leader I want to be and why
should someone follow me so I think
mostly the prep was just thinking
through what I've learned and what are
the things that I want to try today and
there can't be a better way to get like
some really expert feedback from alums
and people who will be judging the event
and hopefully that will play a big role
in how I shape out to be as a leader
completely I think we've worked really
well together all quarter long so we're
feeling pretty confident about today
we've actually spent significantly more
time preparing the cases as Judge
executive challenge than I ever did for
any case in my two years of business
school we're having fun today to say
supposed to be a really great day for
all of us to come together we're really
excited as a us as a unit against the
world or especially getting them ready
for being able to use this type of stuff
in the real world I think it comes very
close to real-life situations that's why
I love coming down here and
participating in it
and it's almost a learning experience
for myself as well I think the biggest
struggle is gonna be coming up with
creative solutions but luckily the team
is really diverse so I think we'll
overcome that challenge today hope to
bring this idea that you know sometimes
just being candid keeping things simple
and understanding the relationships that
exist in the rule you know who's making
the decisions how the decisions are
being made and what the purpose of the
meeting is their way it goes I think we
will be happy because they're gonna get
feedback that is gonna help us grow like
they always say this environment is a
safe environment and we should be it
should be free too
be vulnerable and then get changed you
know so I'm gonna be happy because I
know it's from a good so it's gonna be
happy it's going to have a happy end if
we had to go back and reapply to the GSP
I don't think we can make it the talent
is just is is off the charts we're out
here representing squad 68 and we're
ready to take the bull by the horns
today for executive challenge 68 68 68
but at the same time we're pretty
excited to challenge ourselves you know
get out from our comfort zone
let's go 45 our preparation was some
point yeah it's kind of too bad that we
can't actually go and implement this
idea now cuz we actually really thought
we had a cool idea and it's it's a
strange to get so involved in it for 20
minutes and then have it disappear so
quickly I'm sitting in meetings like
this for the last 25 years as mature
managers I was actively trying to make
sure we like both had equal airtime
because we had slightly different roles
and different priorities but I thought
that actually worked out well for us
yeah and given that there was so much
information it was helpful to know that
Jacqueline had the technology covered
and I mean this is talk more money you
know you really see a wide spectrum of
people flexing skills and had a couple
groups almost come too close to cracking
the case but in any event as a judge
it's a great chance to interact and get
back close with the University it's
amazing an amazing experience
the judges were incredible the feedback
that they gave was super relevant it
built upon things that maybe we'd
already heard during the quarter but
also some new perspectives as well so it
was very very helpful when they came in
with it was like a lot of insightful
questions things that we were trying to
predict before coming into the role play
itself so I I think we did a decent job
I'll have to wait and see what
understanding you got people here with
agendas and dynamics that are going on
how to facilitate it
closing process and that is really
important we had a great time we did not
succeed in achieving our goal but I
think that there was a lot of learning
in the failure day that everybody were
all still people and we still got to
work together right so that to me that's
what I focused on I care less about the
data but how they dealt with each other
and dealt with with us as advisors was
what I was looking for I think we had
some preconceived notions at least in
the case about what certain
personalities would be like and we
prepared for those personalities and
then they didn't let those things show
through really in their personality so
it ended up we had to be a little bit
more dynamic emotionally than we
expected - these guys are very good
they're at a maturity level that's great
so you get a lot of the same kind of
interaction you would with a real
company but like anybody else I think
it's it's fun to see I went quickly you
can accelerate their ability to to pick
up what goes on I mean you like this to
be honest I wish I had had this
opportunity and going through my career
and we kind of had to learn by doing
[Music]